This equals sign shouldn't be here by the way, that's a mistake.
But here they're asking.
in the first in the first
here's how they are translating this.
problem
with the mathematical rotation
fee of
this question the P of this question.
X is within one standard deviation of its me
Okay, so we have two terms here standard deviation
and mean mean of course is the
center.
of
the probability distribution
We said that there are three ways to
measure averages we
have.
mean
median mode but the most important one of them is
is the mean that's where you take.
all the numbers
of the
random variable
add them up and then divide them by.
the amount
the quantity of those values when the random variable I'll show
you the equation if necessary.
But what they're asking is.
What is the probability?
That X is within one standard deviation of its mean.
Let me stop right here and take you to.
the example with the
discrete normal distribution so we can revisit
so we can revisit the
the idea of the probability Mass function and it
will jump back to this.
Three right now you're looking at three.
notations
the first one I told you about it whenever you see an uppercase
letter.
In statistics you're looking at a random variable.
now other letters can be used but
predominantly X is going to be used.
So if you look at this notation up
here.
This is something we're looking at for the first time.
This is red in the following way. We say
X.
The random variable has that's what
this.
Till they sign means.
has
normal distribution
That's what the N means.
okay, don't confuse that uppercase and with a random
variable because this is actually n
What parentheses?
Okay. So were you saying the random variable X has
normal distribution?
At with this mean and this variance.
Okay, the first argument is the mean the second argument
is the variance.